I was going to offer Hershey a rose and
ask her if she would accept this Rose
but she was in such a hurry to get it
[Music]
I'm Gary I'm 72 and I'm your first ever
golden Bachelor today I'm going to be
answering some questions and I get to
play with some adorable Senior Dogs and
I even have some treats for them I have
a senior dog myself actually my dog is
10 years old and she's slowing down a
little bit so yeah I'm thrilled to meet
these dogs this is Zella she's a 13 year
old pit bull she's got a sweet look in
her eye this is Willie and he's 12 years
old you're a good boy this is Hershey
and she's 12 years old as well do you do
tricks look at you so this is ABBA she's
11. isn't that the prettiest thank you
ever saw you can yeah can I get on the
floor what do you think bud
come on
I think this
ain't this here she was
she was lovable
you have to give her the first
impression Rose I think she's kind of a
lover she's a sweet dog
foreign
my daughters and I were texting back and
forth watching The Bachelor and the ad
came on for the senior Bachelor respond
to this.com and My Girls told me I
should probably do that not these girls
my real girls I had nothing to lose I
know but you're being so good here you
go
hello what are you doing hey hey come on
come over here my favorite part would
have to be opening night I do remember
my daughter's giving me a hard time
saying dad you can't make it past 10
o'clock at night as it turns out we
finished that first night about 7 30 in
the morning the producers had to pull me
away from the group because I did not
want it to end
I guess the main thing is playing
pickleball sometimes I'll grab my own
dog and we'll go out onto bulb oh I'm
getting uh somebody over here wanting to
tell me that they would be a good Lake
Dodge
I think the best advice is to stay
positive be hopeful keep your heart open
because it's all too easy at our age to
just figure that your best days are
behind you and that's absolutely not the
case this experience is is one of a
lifetime so you're just always open to
new adventures new invitations
don't say no if somebody comes to look
at you and says maybe we're going to
take you to a forever home just put your
best charm out there and don't say no
the one-on-one dates are pretty
spectacular they're adventuresome
there's a lot of Wide Open Spaces
involved if someone is watching for the
purpose of seeing the one-on-one dates
and how the chemistry is they'll see it
they'll definitely see it these adorable
senior dogs are all available for
adoption from Best Friends Animal
Society just like people senior pets
deserve a second chance at love too join
me on my journey to find love remember
to watch the premiere of The Golden
Bachelor Thursday at 8 7 Central on ABC
and stream on Hulu
[Music]